pop
[Musique]
le 22 mai 1791 dans un couloir obscur
des tuileries trois heures trois hommes
qui se livre un travail assez singulier
on a en effet ménagé dans un mur un
peintre ou un trou profond béant et on
est en train d'appliquer devant ce trou
une porte de fer et celui qui travaille
justement à installer les gonds et
lagache celui là c'est un serrurier qui
s'appelle françois de gamme
à côté de lui le deuxième homme de la
faire c'est un membre du personnel
intérieur des tuileries
l'un des valets de chambre de louis saez
il s'appelle durée et c'est lui qui tend
les outils à gamin est en fait le
troisième homme qui brandit une bougie
pour éclairer les deux autres ce
troisième homme c'est louis seize
derniers rois de france ou plutôt pour
reprendre les termes de la constitution
dernier roi des français
pourquoi ces hommes sont ils réunis là
c'est justement toute l'histoire de ce
qu'il est convenu d'appeler l'armoire de
fait
damart fr vouloir l'évoquer c'est
évoquer une étrange aventure mais je
crois que c'est aussi peut-être une
possibilité d'aller plus loin et d'aller
à la rencontre d'un dès personnages les
plus déconcertant finalement de
l'histoire et janot mais louis saez un
homme que si longtemps après nous
n'arrivons pas à bien comprendre à bien
expliquer alors racontant l'histoire de
l'art moines fait elle avait commencé
bien avant la révolution cette histoire
puisque bien avant la révolution il y
avait au 7 boulevard du roi à versailles
l'atelier le fort bel atelier d'un
serrurier qui s'appelait nicolas gamma
et qui avait la fierté de sa lancée
serrurier du roi n'interprétait pas
cette annonce comme le fait qu'il est
une charge à la cour non pas du tout il
était comme beaucoup d'artisans comme
beaucoup de commerçants de versailles
l'un des fournisseurs de la cour il faut
bien dire que tout ce petit monde qui
travaillait à versailles travail et
surtout pour la cour alors nicolas gamme
avait obtenu d'avoir la charge de toutes
les serrures enfin d'une partie des
serrures de versailles et dieu sait s'il
y en avait et il l'a envoyée pour
réparer pour entretenir pour graisser
c'est pour remplacer éventuellement ses
serrures qu'il envoyait son fils qui
s'appelait françois françois gamin qui
était né en 1751 et qu'ils ont à la
veille de la révolution avait 37
françois gamin n'était pas une lumière
il ne passait pas pour un génie dans la
famille mais enfin c'était un très bel
ouvriers tout le monde s'accordait
là-dessus et il faisait bien son travail
quand tu l'aller à versailles dans le
chêne et le faisais si bien qu'un jour
il était là en train de travailler
quelqu'un s'arrêta pour le regarder
travailler ce quelqu'un c'était tout
simplement le roi louis xi est le roi
louis saez semble-t-il fut enchanté de
l'habileté de l'ouvrier de l'habileté du
serrurier et une idée lui passa par la
tête
comme ce serait amusant si lui le roi il
apprenait la serrures
l'idée n'est pas resté hallyday à l'état
d'hypothèse
le roi a parlé avec gamins et on
l'installé dans les combles du château
au dessus de la bibliothèque
particulière du roi on installe un
atelier de serrurerie
c'est même durée qui en a été chargé
c'est dur et qui a apporté peu à peu
tous les ustensiles qui a installé la
petite frange qui a installé les taux
dont on avait besoin qui existe toujours
qui a installé les différents ustensiles
les différents outils et notamment deux
opte est désormais de longues heures
pendant de longues heures
louis saez s'est enfermé dans sa série
avec gamme et de loser il a travaillé
avec une sorte de bonheur peut-être bien
que avant la révolution c'est là dans
son atelier de serrurerie que louis saez
a été le plusieurs alors quand il avait
fini qu de fabriquer une serrure par
exemple ou bien une combinaison
quelconque de serrurerie fier de lui
alors il mentait sur le toit où il y
avait sorte de belvédère
rue avec un bon fauteuil bien télescope
et puis avec ce télescope ils le
regardaient dans les cour de versailles
dans les jardins et puis au delà dans la
ville au delà de la cour d'honneur dans
les jardins des particuliers
il y prenait le plus grand plaisir
simple divertissement divertissement
d'un homme simple quel malheur que cet
homme simple et bon étaient des rois un
jour il cachait autant que possible ses
activités de serrurerie
m'enfin on en parlait on s'en amuse et
on n'en nommer à la cour et un jour où
seize tous fiers a montrée à thierry de
ville d'avray une de ses réussites en
serrurerie regarder et thierry de ville
d'avray a répondu si c'est très bien
mais quand les rois font la besogne des
peuples il arrive que les peuples face
la besogne des rois et c'est ce qui est
arrivé je ne vous apprends rien
les états généraux le 14 juillet
la prise de la bastille et vous savez
que le soir sur son fameux carnets louis
saez a écrit 14 juillet rien et puis
surtout les journées des 5 et 6 octobre
quand le peuple de paris les femmes de
paris march sur versailles pour aller
chercher le boulanger la boulangère elle
petit mitron le roi la reine et le
dauphin parce que les temps sont très
durs parce que l'on a peur de manquer de
pain et parce qu'on se dit que si ce roi
ce roi qu'on aime est là dans paris
eh bien on sera davantage en sécurité
c'est un sentiment élémentaire est un
sentiment qui dépeint bien les rapports
entre les français et le roi à cette
époque la wii en 1789
aucun doute les français sont
profondément monarchiste ils sont
royalistes ils aiment leur roi
en 1789 robespierre et royaliste en 1789
d'antan et royalistes au le monde et
royalistes à part quelques exceptions
qui se comptent peut-être sur les deux
mains pas plus
et voyez-vous c'est le drame c'est le
drame parce que louis saez ne comprends
pas
il comprend six peut qu en octobre 89
oui écoutez bien cette date déjà en
octobre 89
ils adressent secrètement au roi charles
iv d'espagne une protestation solennelle
contre tout ce qu'il a accepté depuis le
14 juillet tous nal il a concédé à son
corps défendant il proteste il dit non
non je ne vais pas volu c'est ça le
drame parce que ces français qui aiment
le roi a qui veulent la révolution car
ils veulent que ça change
ils veulent que ce soit mieux que ce
soit meilleur
il voudrait tant que ce soit avec laure
leroy ne comprend pas et le roi et la
reine ne comprennent pas ils ne
comprendront jamais on a l'habitude
voyez vous de dire que c'est la reine
que c'est marie antoinette qui entraîné
son faible mari ça n'est pas tout à fait
vrai bien sûr elle est plus fiers les
plus orgueilleuse et lui plus + bonasse
mais il pense comme elle
et pour lui il y à une évidence c'est
que son pouvoir son pouvoir absolu il
lui vient de dieu et que tout ce qui va
contre ce pouvoir absolu va contre dieu
en octobre 90 un an plus tard la
constitution et bien on s'aperçoit
qu'elle va fonctionner louis n'est plus
qu'un droit constitutionnel et puis
aussi les sections populaire dans paris
travail font entendre leur voix
c'est au nom de ces sections qu'un
avocat incertain dans ton est venu à
l'assemblée a réclamé la démission des
ministres et les ministres ont
démissionné oui voilà le rôle déjà des
sections de paris et tout cela pour
louis saez tout cela tout ce que je dis
est tout ce que je ne dis pas car c'est
un monde qui s'affrontent à louis saez
tout cela ne peut pas le comprendre il
ne peut pas non plus le tolérer
et c'est en octobre à la fin d'octobre
90 qu'on peut dire que louis saez a
basculé dans la contre révolution
jusque là il avait subi maintenant il
attaque et on ne peut pas assister sans
une émotion véritable à ce combat qui
n'aurait pas dû se fait et qui s'est
fait parce que l'homme qui était là la
tête du pays n'était pas l'homme qu'il
aurait fallu pour cette situation là
alors on commence déjà à lier des
relations secrètes avec les pays
étrangers on prépare un appel à ces pays
étrangers on souhaite donc des armées
étrangères éventuellement viennent aider
à la restauration du pouvoir légitime du
roi louis saez sur les français et
c'est le moment des bus 91 après qu'en
décembre 90 enfin louis saez est accepté
de signer de ratifier la constitution
civile du clergé il y avait mis des des
semaines retardant
car c'est cela sa politique à
l'extérieur traité secrètement avec les
autres rois à l'intérieur ralentir la
machine et après qu'il ait signé cette
constitution civile du clergé qui
quillan havrais profondément et bien au
début 91 il pense déjà à la possibilité
d'agir plus efficacement et donc de
partir oui parce que la fuite est donc
une solution ça n'est pas une suite pour
le sl c'est un départ il ira à montmédy
retrouvera l'armée de bouyer et puis là
tendra la main aux autrichiens voilà ce
qu'on est en train de négocier
bien sûr cela va coûter cher car
l'autriche demandera l'alsace l'espagne
si elle intervient demandera la navarre
l'angleterre pour prix de sa seule
neutralité demande déjà les colonies
mais enfin au moins le roi sera s'est
rétablie sur son tronc
il faut quand même pas voyez vous être
manichéen en histoire cet homme ils
souffrent réellement profondément il ne
comprend pas donc il souffrait justement
cette affaire de la constitution civile
du clergé et bien pour lui c'est un
déchirement réel il ne sait pas s'il va
pouvoir communier et ce tome qui est un
chrétien un grand chrétien profondément
sincère qui a une fois vrai et puis on
bien plus que ses prédécesseurs qui
n'avaient qu'une fois de théâtre pour la
plupart mais cet homme là est déchiré et
il faut le plaindre et je le plains en
février 91
mesdames celle qu'on l'appelle mesdames
c'est à dire les filles de louis 15 les
tentes de louis saez parts elle quitte
la france est cette sorte de d'émeutes
la foule vient aux tuileries la foule
vient à siéger les tuileries
on ne comprend pas pourquoi par tél et
c'est de ce moment là qu'une idée secret
en france la famille royale en somme
c'est l'otage de la révolution c'est
l'otage du peuple cette famille a des
privilèges en france elle n'a pas le
droit de les abandonner comme ça
d'un geste d'un mouvement louis saez et
marie antoinette sont frappés par cette
réaction du peuple face à leur tante 4
mars 91 louis saez sa lite
il est souffrant il est malade de corps
une crash même le sens mais il est
malade de l'âme son confesseur l'abbé
poupart a juré
car la france maintenant divisé le
clergé français divisé maintenant jure
heures ceux qui ont accepté la
constitution civile du clergé et les
autres qu'ils ont fusé qui sont les
réfractaires
alors lui louis saez qui le premier
fonctionnaire de l'état se doit d'avoir
un confesseur qu'ils soient joueurs
et pourtant il veut plus de l'abbé pupa
il va prendre un autre prêtre l'abbé et
lui demander si pour park qui approche
il va pouvoir communier la bébert le
pense mais ça n'est pas assez pour louis
saez qui s'adresse à l'évêque de
clairement lequel répond non si on ne
communiquait pas vous n'en avez pas le
droit près ce que vous avez fait voilà
qui accroît les tourments de cet homme
plaignent on le met en même temps
soyons lucides et restons très lucide en
même temps pendant que se passe c'est
réel tourments et bien on lit de plus en
plus les relations avec les nations
étrangères
et maintenant on vient d'aboutir avec
léopold ii d'autriche
le but c'est quoi le but est bien cédé
que le roy quitte la france s'associe à
des étrangers pour faire la guerre à qui
à la france et ça c'est une chose tout
de même
même si on essaye de le comprendre cet
homme là est bien on l'a beaucoup de mal
le lundi 6 1 il monte en voiture avec la
reine ils veulent partir pour saint
cloud et voilà que la garde nationale
qui est là pour garder les tuileries sa
troupe
on a constaté que le roi à la messe du
dimanche n'avaient pas communier
alors s'il va monter en voiture c'est
sans doute pour aller communier à saint
cloud et la troupe la garde nationale
n'en veut pas il faut que le roi soit
fidèle à son serment fidèle à l'état
fidèle à cette constitution que les
français appellent alors on empêche la
voiture n'a pas retiré sa dure 1h30 un
tumulte épouvantable lafayette qui veut
faire tirer louis saez qui refusent ou
c'est ce qui remonte dans ses
appartements la reine qui vient lui dire
vous voyez bien que nous ne sommes pas
allés
il le sait il ya longtemps qu'il le sait
mais il ne tenait qu'à lui de l'être
il va quand même à l'assemblée il jure
qu'il n'a qu'une préoccupation faire le
bonheur de ses peuples et ça n'est pas
vrai parce que maintenant ces peuples il
a pour eux un sentiment d'amertume de
mépris des reproches il écrit où
s'ouvrait étrangers que il est libre oui
oui je suis libre affirme-t-il et quand
il écrit il c'est la rage au coeur parce
qu'on lui a demandé de le faire et le
départ est maintenant décider pour laver
fixés d'abord au 19 mai puis on leur
portera au 19 juin et enfin au 20 juin
c'est justement à cette époque que
françois gamin va entendre parler de
nouveaux de louis saez françois gamin
qui comme tous ces artisans et
commerçants de versailles a pâti
considérablement du départ de la cour
vous pensez bien eu plus de cours alors
plus de travail et il y à une sorte de
misère déjà au domicile des gamins et
voilà que gamins voient arriver durée
son cher vieux duret a duré à un gamin
qui se retrouvent et durée vient
simplement proposé à gamma de partir
pour paris
pourquoi paris pour voir le roi on ne
refuse pas de voir le roi et puis aussi
une arrière pensée sur manche est gamin
on a presque fin maintenant la maison et
si je vois le roi peut-être que tout va
changer
c'est tout de même encore toujours le
roi louis saez à cette époque
et voilà où ça se passe au début de mai
81 11
et voilà gamin a mené aux tuileries et
introduit chez louis saez qui
certainement ne voit pas sans émotion
rentrée l'homme qui lui a appris la
serrurerie et luis et explique la faire
il a des papiers beaucoup de papier ne
dit pas bien entendu qui va s'en aller
l'huile le sexe à cuba sandell et la
question qui s'étaient posés c'était ses
papiers des papiers d'une considérable
importance politique par exemple les
papiers qui montre que mirabaud l'idole
de la nation l'idole du peuple bien
temps hissé sans vergogne le peuple
profil louis saez parce que louis saez à
mu avait payé 200 mille livres de dettes
et 6000 livres par mois
il y avait beaucoup d'autres choses très
graves qui aller très loin et louis saez
n'avait pas la possibilité d'emporter
ses papiers
par ailleurs les détruire inique n'est
pas parce que dans son esprit quand il
partait c'était pour revenir et quand il
reviendrait serais très content de
pouvoir tout à coup des masques et les
impostures alors l'idée lui était venue
de garder ses papiers jusqu'à son retour
pendant son absence dans un lieu secret
tout ça il ne disait pas gamin il disait
simplement que pour mettre des papiers
mais il avait besoin d'une sorte
d'armoires et l'entraîné gamins dans le
couloir qui joignait la propre chambre
du roy la chambre royale à celle du
dauphin un couloir qui était décoré de
boiseries et ses boiseries était peinte
en forme de pierre
un peu bizarre d'ailleurs ne peindre sur
du bois des pierres n'y a qu'à montrer
des pires si ça passait comme ça c'est
la décoration du temps et on n'a donc
pas des pierres sur les boules et en
enlevant l'une de ces fausses pierres en
bois louis saez a démasqué un trou que
le l'on commencé à creuser dans le mur
il a expliqué que dure et commencer un
ménage et l'excavation importante dans
le mur et que ce qu'il voulait lui louis
sais c'est que gamin fabrique une porte
de fait à la dimension de l'ouverture de
ce trou et qu'il vienne l'appliquer de
manière car ce que cette porte soit
fermée à clé que personne ne puisse
accéder
après quoi remettrai le le décor en bois
devant et personne ne s'apercevrait de
rien et c'est ce qui a été fait durée et
le roi ont travaillé pendant trois nuits
pour ménager le trop est dur et prenez
tous les gravats dans des serviettes et
il a les peler les porter dans la seine
il a fait six voyages pendant ce temps
dans sa forge gamin fabriquer la porte
de fer et cette porte de fer il a mis 3
jours et 3 nuits à la forge et et puis
tout est prêt nous sommes le 22 mai 1791
le soir
gamin est introduit par les cuisines aux
tuileries
personne ne le voit c'est dur et qu'il a
introduit il apporte sa porte
et maintenant dans le couloir voilà que
le trou est entièrement terminée
c'est un trou qui à peu près 60 cm de
fond qui a 40 mètres de diamètre à
l'entrée et qui va d'ailleurs en se
resserrant vers le fond et maintenant
gamin va mettre sa porte qui à zéro m 48
on est on a des chiffres précis des
rapports précis va mettre sa porte
devant le trou il va sceller des gonds
pour la porte et puis une gâche tout
cela va prendre des heures
c'est là que le roi et la tenant sa
bougie pour éclairer gamme jeu puis tout
était remis tout est terminé gamin verra
déjà les premiers papiers engouffrés
dans le trou cependant que le roi lui
donnera un rouleau de louis et puis
comme il fait soif comme il fait chaud
un verre de vin rouge que gamin d'à -
est gamin va rentrer à versailles tout
de suite après examen depuis quelques
temps souffre beaucoup de lait sommes
las de cruels ils éprouvent de cruelles
douleurs d'estomac est ce que se demande
si ce n'est pas les malheurs du temps
vous savez le mot ulcéré a bien un sens
précis et
louis saez ne saura jamais contre tours
de versailles gamin va restituer tout ce
qu'il a absorbé dans la journée de
manière à plus tard pouvoir tracer une
sorte de conte de contes étranges sur
lequel nous revient
le départ va se fait le départ pour
varennes vous connaissez cette histoire
départ de toute la famille royale le roi
la reine
madame de tourvel madame elisabeth mal
amoyal le petit dauphin départ dans une
énorme voiture on va voyager comme au
cours d'une partie de campagne alors
qu'un petit cabriolet à un cheval ou à
gauche pour est emmené tous ces gens
très vite loin de paris et finalement
sera pris vous le savez à varennes
maître de poste
il appelle nous et on arrête la voiture
on on arrête la voiture je suis je
m'arrête un tout petit instant vous
devez être surpris par mois des billets
7 ccc si vous voulez une occasion pour
moi tout à coup de m'expliquer avec vous
même si l'histoire rien de s'interrompre
quelques formes me dit vous prenez des
temps vous prenez des silences en
général c'est qu'il se passe quelque
chose
il vient tout simplement de m'arriver
une aventure ma caméra vienne tombé en
panne et j'ai eu sous les yeux tout un
petit balai on vient de me changer la
caméra sous les yeux c'est très
difficile de garder le fil de ses idées
c'est pourquoi vous m'avez vu tout à
coup on m'a demandé ce qu'il arrivait à
gamma sur la route de versailles vient
maintenant je vous le redis pardon pour
l'incident pardon pour l'incident
surtout donc varennes de samawa ray et à
varennes on arrête la famille royale on
la ramène à paris
et cette famille royale est maintenant
prisonniers
la suite est bien la suite ce sera sept
la suite ce sera l'histoire de france ce
sera l'explication voulu par la majorité
de l'assemblée d'un enlèvement du roi
la suite ce sera la guerre la guerre
déclarée follement malgré les
objurgations d'un homme qui voyait clair
qui s'appelait robespierre et cette
guerre qui voulue par le roi et la reine
qui maintenant joue serré beaucoup plus
serrée dans cet état de demi prison où
ils sont le jeu devient de plus en plus
difficile alors justement la guerre est
bien la guerre on espère qu'elle sera
désastreuse et l'on fait tout pour cela
puisque marie antoinette dès les débuts
de cette guerre comme unique halle aux
ennemis les plans de l'armée française
et ça ce sont des choses on a beau
vouloir comprendre pourra jamais
et c'est le divorce irrémédiable entre
le peuple et la monarchie et c'est le
peuple qui entrent aux tuileries le 20
juin
et c'est le peuple qui entre de nouveau
depuis lors ils disent ou 92 et cette
fois c'est la fin de la royauté la
famille royale est maintenant prise au
nez à la tour du temple
ils attendent dans cette tour du temple
leur sort
et leur sort inéluctable c'est de rendre
des comptes
louis saez dans sa tour du temple sait
qu'il va être jugé et gamme et car nous
avons deux personnages dans cette
histoire un bon louis saez que nous
suivons et nous avons gamin est gamin et
bien gamme un gamin a reçu du galon
gamin est maintenant aux fonctionnaires
il est membre du conseil général de la
commune de versailles et bientôt même
après le dise où on va le nommer membre
d'une commission chargée de d'effacer
les emblèmes royaux dans versailles ça
n'était certainement pas une petite
affaire
mes gamins a peur
et ça nous le savons
gama voit l'histoire suivre son
mouvement irrésistible voir maintenant
le roi détrôné le roi prisonniers et lui
gamme ne pense qu'à une chose il ne
pense qu'à cette nuit au cours de
laquelle il a scellé l'armoire de fait
et lui à qui on fait confiance lui que
l'on traite comme un patriote lui à qui
l'on donne des emplois s'est dit mais
enfin si jamais on apprenait et nous
savons qu'il est allé plusieurs fois à
paris aux nouvelles il y avait une
commission qui travaillait dans les
papiers de louis saez
on essayait de trouver dans cet océan de
papier qu'il y avait aussi évident
d'essayer des preuves contre louis saez
est il allé aux aguets ils posaient des
questions en apparence anodine et non
non on n'avait rien trouvé
et plus les semaines passent et plus
cette erreur grandissait et bientôt il
n'a pas pu lui tenir c'était le 20
novembre
92 il est allé à paris de bon matin a
demandé audience au ministre de
l'intérieur
roland a été reçue et à tout raconte
roland relance et un girondin
c'est aussi le mari de la belle madame
roland l'égérie des girondins c'est en
quelque sorte l'épicentre du mouvement
girondins et les girondins ne sont pas
toujours à l'aise dans le développement
qui se fait de la révolution les
girondins ont été pour les solutions
extrêmes ils ne sont plus et surtout les
girondins et roland se souviennent que
dans les derniers temps avant le 10 où
il y a eu quelques tractations avec le
roi qu'on n'aimerait pas connaître il y
a eu des lettres que les girondins ont
fait passer au roi par l'intermédiaire
du pâtre morose
erland ailleurs depuis qu'il est
ministre de l'intérieur et depuis qu'il
est là demande chaque jour si l'on n'a
pas trouvé des lettres et oui on a les
lettres des girondins et même marc amara
qui quelquefois emery et qui sait très
bien qu'elles sont les terreurs de
roland mara très sérieusement dénoncer
un fait qui se serait passé à la veille
du 10 où et comme quoi marie antoinette
aurait déversé des quantités de papier
dans une fosse d'aisance alors
immédiatement relancé porté vers cette
fosse d'aisance
on ya fait descendre des hommes de l'art
qui ont fouillé dans ce que vous pensez
pourrir en extraire des papiers il y
avait des papiers bien sûr qu'elle met
des papiers et on les at on l'étendait à
roland qui était au dessus avec un
courage extraordinaire et qui recevait
les papiers avec une pincette les
plonger dans du vinaigre les mondiaux
les laisser macérer à l'instant et puis
ensuite essayé de les lire ça a duré
quelques jours après quoi
mara dans un immense éclat de rire dit
que c'était une blague alors rolland qui
voilà arrivés gamins et bien croit voir
l'envoyer la providence et les employés
qui arriveront les employés des
tuileries qui arriveront pourront
apercevoir ils en ont témoigné
roland montant précipitamment le grand
escalier des tuileries avec gamin donc
de bon matin et traversé la chambre des
gardes s'est dirigé vers la chambre du
roi brisé les scellés n'y en a aucun
droit d'ailleurs et disparaître dans la
chambre du roy avec cet homme inconnu
dont les employés disent qu'il avait le
teint très jour une preuve qu'il était
toujours malade de l'estomac l'homme au
teint jaune distincts est-ce que vas tu
faire
rolland s'est passé dans le petit
couloir conduit par gamme un gamin
enlèvera le morceau de boiseries qui
dissimule la cachette et avec la clé qui
l'a toujours
il ouvrira la remarque de faire et ce
sera pour roland le plus merveilleux des
moments d'ailleurs plus tard une gravure
allégorique évoquera ce moment-là et
montrera rolland est gamin devant
l'armoire de faire devant une fosse
armoires de faire parce que la porte est
gigantesque et puis de la porte ouverte
qu'est ce qu'il sort à ce que l'être
c'est le squelette de mirabeau et où il
faut dire que l'un des hommes les plus
compromis dans cette affaire sera
mirabeau alors il reste très longtemps
là dans cette chambre dans ce couloir
roland puisque ça n'est que à 11h et
nuit entre 11h30 11h45 qu'il va quitter
la chambre du roy et ça n'est qu'à deux
heures et quart qu'il va entrer dans les
locaux de la convention qu'est ce qu'il
a encore fait entre temps dans les
locaux la convention il la convention
est en séance
roland s'avance demande la parole est
immédiatement explique qui vient de se
passer quelque chose d'extraordinaire
que enfin les papiers ces fameux papier
eh bien il les a et on va pouvoir les
dépouiller et on va pouvoir en accablé
louis saez
alors il y a immédiatement des gens qui
s'étonnent goupilleau par exemple
goupilleau et camille desmoulins camille
desmoulins qui prend la parole
camille desmoulins qui dit mais enfin
pourquoi pourquoi monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur pourquoi le ministre de
l'intérieur pourquoi le citoyen roland
n'at-il pas appeler avec lui une
commission lorsqu'il a ouvert l'armoire
de faire n'at-il pas trier des documents
et c'est en effet le tout sans que tout
le monde ressent et qui est très
plausible
disons le en tous les cas ces documents
les a on les a et les apporte la preuve
je les dis donc de la trahison de
mirabaud mais apporte aussi les la
preuve des tractations de louis saez
avec les émigrés ces immigrés que louis
saez condamné hautement et qui en fait
étaient ses correspondants on a la
preuve des relations des tractations
avec dumouriez avec lafayette avec
l'abbé maurice on a la preuve et les
sommes même que l'on a donné pour
acheter des journaux pour acheter des
imprimeurs des journalistes
les sommes que l'on est distribué à
certains députés les sommes que l'on est
distribué à des espions qui était dans
les clubs et aussi dans certaines
sections populaire même tout cela en lan
dans ses papiers et ce sera pour luis m
alors que va s'ouvrir son procès
l'élément déterminant qui viendra
l'accablent séance du 11 décembre louis
saez est là devant ses juges celui qui
l'interrogent c'est barrère le président
de la convention barrère c'est lui ce
qu'il y a dans l'armoire de faire louis
saez ne le sait pas elle ignore même
qu'on la trouve l armoire de fer d'où
ces réponses terrible épouvantable
avez vous donné de l'argent à certains
non non vous at on proposé des plans
révolutionnaire et dans ce cas citer des
noms
on est venu moment proposé mais je me
souviens l'okano reconnaissez vous votre
écriture sur ce document non je ne
reconnais pas mon écrit t attends
ménages et aux tuileries une armoire de
faits non non non cette clé c'est la clé
de la moins le faire savez vous ce que
ca non non pas du tout et quand on lit
encore aujourd'hui la sténographie de
ces interrogatoires
on est atterré
on voit cet homme on voit cet homme qui
s'en faire et pourtant quand on la parle
et d'armoires de fer n'aurait-il pas dû
comprendre alors l'épreuve de l'art
marre de faire s'ajoutant à toutes les
autres et dieu sait s'il y en a combien
ils sont gras ses preuves la l'ont fait
condamner condamné à mort à la veille de
noël
92 alors ils se préparent à mourir et
disons le il se prépare avec une dignité
qui force le respect il y a de ces gens
qui sont inférieures à leur vie et qui
sont égaux à leur mort louis saez est de
ceux là
il fait ses adieux à sa famille
et va monter sur l'échafaud ou sans s'en
fera tomber sa tête
gamin ah oui revenons à gamin je vous ai
dit de rôles de personnages aussi
lointain qu'il soit louis saez gamins et
bien gamin est devenu célèbre
son nom est sur toutes les bouches
il est malade très malade est ce que il
a des remords au personne ne nous l'a
dit nous n'en savons rien il a trahi son
maître il a trahi un homme qui avait été
toujours bien pour lui qu'il ne lui
avait fait que du bien
et par cette trahison cet homme était
allé à la mort
il est malade et il écrit il écrit un
jour peut-être t-il le cerveau dérangé
peut-être va-t-il davantage il écrit un
jour à la convention nous sommes en
janvier 94
il explique qu'une chose inouïe
il explique que le roi et vous vous
souvenez que c'est vrai lui a donné un
verre de vin le soir du 22 mai 81 11
et il rappelle que en effet il a été
malade en chemin entre paris et
versailles mais déjà son estomac était
délabré et espagne normal qu'ils étaient
malades mais non pas du tout dix gamins
la convention ça n'est pas ça du tout
c'est que le verre de vin était
empoisonnée et voilà tout le roman
feuilleton que gamin raconte dans sa
pétition à la convention il y joue un
certificat médical lequel certificat
médical d'ailleurs et très prudemment
rédigées puisque les médecins écrivent
qu'ils ont constaté en effet que gamin
était malade mais ils ne disent pas
pourquoi comment et un témoignage de
témoignage de l'un des médecins qui a
été publié récemment par l'ape levron un
témoignage nous dit que les médecins
n'ont pas volontairement voulu mentir et
qu' il n'avait vu aucun des effets du
poison dans l'état de leurs clients d'où
leur certificat il est malade
ben oui il est malade s'engageait pas
davantage et pourtant la convention va
croire ce roman feuilleton
un certain musset un député se fera le
rapporteur de cette affaire mais chose
inouïe la convention reconnaîtra par un
vote que gamin a été empoisonné par
louis saez un crime de plus beau louiset
et elle lui donnant une pension une
pension de 12 100 livres par an à dater
du jour de l'empoisonnement jours
d'ailleurs fixé curieusement par gamins
dans son récit dans sa pétition au mois
de mai 92 alors il a dû regretter
d'avoir donné une fausse date puisque à
cause de ce mensonge mensonge
compréhensible qui ne tenait pas ce
qu'on se souvienne qu'il avait construit
l'armoire de faire un an et demi avant
il aurait mis bien longtemps à dénoncer
ce travail tandis que si c'était six
mois avant ça se comprenait mais à cause
de ce mensonge presque obligé eh bien il
allait toucher sa pension avec un an de
retard et n'allait pas la toucher
l'autre le 8 mai 95 à 43 ans
gamin mouret
alors voilà l'art marre de faire pour
moi l'armoire de faire c'est avant tout
deux scènes la première louis saez
brandissant sa bougie devant ces hommes
qui s'affairent devant un trou noir là
dans un mur la deuxième rôle en
s'extasiant devant le même trou qui
vient de lui être ouvert et où il voit
les papiers les papiers à la fois qu'ils
redoutaient qu'ils espèrent mais les
deux scènes ses anecdotes dans la
perspective de cette explication louis
saez que nous avons tenté que nous
devons essayer de tenter en si peu de
temps
moi ce qui me hante ses l'interrogatoire
du 11 décembre ce sont ces questions
et ce document le reconnaissez vous non
c'est votre écriture non l'armoire de
faire vous connaissez non avez vous
donné de l'argent non ce n'est pas
seulement pour cela que la convention
nationale l'a condamné louis 16 mai nous
qui n'avons qu'un jugement face à
l'histoire a prononcé c'est peut-être à
travers cet interrogatoire que nous
serons tentés de le condamner
[Musique]